hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to will you press the button now
you guys said that you liked the more
relaxed calm sexy let's play when I did
the world's quietest let's play so I
thought I'd split the difference with
something that was actually pretty
appropriate for it will you press the
button even opens up with the perfect
question for this Morgan Freeman will
narrate your life for as long as you
live but he insults you on every
decision you make I don't even care if
he was insulting me telling me I'm a
terrible person throwing me into a well
and beating me with sticks
if Morgan Freeman could narrate my
entire life I would take that chance
because that is absolutely amazing how
many out you out there how many out
there would want me to narrate your life
if all I was doing was insulting you is
that a good option I'll leave that up to
you
Quidditch becomes an official sport
played in world tournaments and in
schools but you're never able to play it
okay so this is a selfish question if I
were to rob everyone of the joy of
Quidditch which is exactly the world
that we have or everyone else gets to
enjoy Quidditch but I can only watch it
I mean to be honest have you noticed how
many times people get hurt and die in
Quidditch I don't even know if it would
be done anywhere else but underground
Quidditch rings so I guess I'd press the
button just for everyone else benefit if
not my own no there's 44% of the world
that's a bunch of selfish bastards if I
can't do it no one can
it's pretty good lemma you have the
ability to become a Super Saiyan but you
can only speak in loud annoying me
that's really funny to be it's because
pretty much all you guys for me are
really loud annoying yells so I guess I
would take that because my normal life
would change all that much except for
the fact that I could dare to do it
super save oh that's so perfect I don't
know why this particular round is so
perfect for me oh man it's amazing you
learn what the Fox says but you can
never talk again now is that saying I
couldn't talk in normal words that
people could understand so I would never
be able to tell people what the [ __ ] you
know that's stupid I didn't even like
the music video all that much in the
first place that's dumb I need to talk
it's my life I can go on assuming that
the Fox says he but Matt put in what the
Fox said
thank you you have mastered all four
elements
but you spend all your time saving the
world over and over again okay now this
is that this is a question of specifics
are you talking about The Legend of
Korra
you know avatar world because that's
completely different than mastering four
elements in the traditional sense
because there's more than four elements
so if you're not very specific on this
one I'm gonna assume that you mean
avatar levels and in that case I have to
spend all my time saving the world over
and over again basically I'm superhero
that gives my life purpose even though
it's a fruitless task it keeps getting
into trouble I'd be a hero and be able
to do amazing things you're granted
complete and unlimited ability to time
travel into effect past and future
events without being subject to
paradoxes but your life is removed from
the time stream you still exist but
every event in the oven in your life
before you started the time travel never
happened so you would completely cease
to exist so you'd kind of be like um
this wandering stranger throughout all
of time able to affect everyone else but
everything that happened before is
removed so Who I am as a person it's
removed and nobody remembers me and no
one even knew I exist I would say hell
yes I would take that it would just kind
of be like transitioning or ascending
into a higher life you know and then
this weird unlimited ability to time
travel that's so fantastic and
interesting now that doesn't mean that I
live forever I'm assuming but just being
able to do that even if all of Mark
Fischbach is gone like God from
existence that would be phenomenal I'll
take that chance thank you
oh all your ass and future memes will
get featured but he will kill alive and
we'll have slow in neck thick uh oh no I
mean uh oh no my poor memes might not
get to be featured on a meme scum
I need my big memes or else my life is
no gain
ha ha ha ha I will take that risk
32% of people it's so sad how dare they
take my memes from me oh man he would
build a time machine but it could take
you to the worst times and you get stuck
there that sounds horrible the worst
times as if before the earth was even
formed and I'd just be floating in space
that's not good at all no no let's see
you can do anything you set your mind to
but you have to do it completely naked
with a crowd of people watching I don't
see a downside to this one all right
sorry everybody I just had to get that
system a little bit I would absolutely
do that that sounds incredible I can do
anything and people get to watch me do
it naked
that's incredible I want to be a
stripper Oh
Oh president you are the immortal
company owner of a video game company
that is extremely successful and you may
do whatever you want whenever but you
may be immortal but that requires you
have taken apart some of yourself to be
replaced with robotic parts which need
checked every year for bugs of course
there is a small chance of corruption
the [ __ ] is this talking
oh no rewrite better you can breathe
underwater but you can only eat raw fish
Hey sushi everyday sounds pretty good to
me that's like my life as it is
oh yeah okay it sounds great I'm down
for that
cool you are given the chance to wipe
Freemasonry off the earth for good but
religions take over the world
atheism and Satanism are both wiped out
as well what is that what do you have
against Freemasonry I mean I know it's
like a secret society but I mean what do
you have against it I don't even
understand that have sex with anyone you
desire but it is the worst sex
experience of your life and you don't
get an orgasm then what's even the point
like why would you take that who cares
if you I get to have sex with anyone you
desire it's terrible
they're gonna remember it if it's
someone famous they're gonna tell
stories about how legendarily bad but I
will not press that button oh man your
favorite fictional character is in love
with you but their touch will severely
burn you I don't know if I answered this
one before
ooh but it is interesting I don't know
who my favorite fictional character
would be who's your favorite fictional
character who's your wife or husband Oh
which one's rich see I'm trying to think
the last video game I played that had
like a romantic aspect about it but one
of my favorite game series of all time
is Mass Effect and in Mass Effect I
played every variety I've romanced every
character both male and female like I
played through the games probably
hundreds and hundreds of hours put into
the game to get every possible option
but my favorite was actually Tali I I
don't know why I like Li are a lot but I
like for some reason like Tali was
interesting to me because she was like
this special case where she couldn't
actually get close to anyone and that
was kind of interesting so this is kind
of the same scenario where the actual
physical touch is very dangerous so that
kind of goes hand in hand that's not my
favorite fictional character but the
only one that comes to mind that relates
to this scenario so not stepping on
anyone's Mass Effect waifu er husbando
toes here to say in this kind of relates
sure whatever you can eat smoke drink
and do drugs as much as you want and you
will have perfect health but you die at
40 um to be perfectly honest I'll take
the risk of just living out my life and
maybe I won't die at 40 besides why
would you want to do drugs as much as
you want you go so out of your mind it
would be scary not that I have a vast
experience with drugs but I've heard
horror stories with people like taking
too much weed or too much LSD or
something like that and it just becomes
a horribly uncomfortable experience why
not just do it in moderation not again
mark pliers not telling everyone to go
out and run do as many drugs as you want
that's not what I'm saying I'm not even
saying do it in moderation just do it
safely whatever I'm not judging but I
mean like why would you bother don't
even take the risk no I will not and
stupid you can eat your favorite food
when
ever you want but three people you love
can only eat cereal for their whole
lives um I think I know more than three
people that eat cereal every day of
their life and if that means that I can
eat chicken and dumplings every day
whenever I want
I'm taking that risk so hell yes I'm oh
come on how is the minority not that
button I love it and they got there
there's a huge variety of [ __ ] oh they
can pick anything they want anything you
are awesome but no one but you recognize
it so it's pretty much my everyday life
and it is I know I'm awesome but no one
else acknowledges it it's not my fault
that they don't acknowledge it hell yeah
I'd press that button amazing age five
times slower but all your friends and
family lovers and children will outgrow
you see this kind of like the living for
narrative forever scenarios and I've
stated my mind on this one I personally
do not want to live forever I think that
living forever is just a selfish
endeavor and not like it's just not
supposed to be that way to me first I
know there's people out there would be
like I would love to live forever you
know I don't want to die but like me
personally I know and I accept and I
understand and I kind of feel like it's
a part of my life for my life to end
someday I definitely don't want to see
all of my friends and family and lovers
and children outgrow me
I would have to bury every child that I
ever had even if I was only going five
times slower it would not be good like
in my mind unless there was some bigger
reason for me to live longer I think
I'll take actually this is an
interesting question and not like
because you guys obviously have a wide
variety of opinions about that and there
are people out there who would not miss
this opportunity for the world and and I
understand that but I'd like to know
more about your opinion and help me
understand deeper about why you would
want to live forever versus why someone
would not so give me your opinions give
me your personal answers about this one
in the comments below thank you
everybody so much for watching and let
me know what you think thanks again
everybody laptop oh God